this study which was mainly the work of
Eric bugera a wonderful postdoc this
work has to do with developing a model
for a repetitive disorder where we could
then experimentally get at the
compulsion the kind of compulsive
behavior of the little model Mouse and
then looking through the brain to find
out what circuit is abnormal and could
we cure a compulsion that we were
looking at in this mouse Eric would drop
a little drop of water on the nose of
the mouse and these mice would grew
their compulsive behavior in the model
is to over groom so we thought well why
don't we try to condition the grooming
with this drop of water water drops the
animal crews and we would play a tone
before the water drops and pretty soon
the animal would learn by standard
pebble area and conditioning that the
tone means the waters gonna come and so
what happens in the normal Mouse is he
learns and the tone comes he starts
gloomy even another water drop hasn't
come and we found the compulsive Mouse
he did the same thing but the normal
mice the wild-type mice big work it so
they they started grooming just before
the water drop occurred that was key to
us it turns out because the admirable
mouse the compulsive Mouse he never did
that just if a toy he won once he
learned he just groovy gloomy room if so
what we did in the experiment was we
decided we would record from the brain
so what we used was this little device
this head stage so it's implanted on the
head of the mouse and then you can
recall the neural activity either in the
in the cortex or the stratum so you can
like basically monitor the activity
during the behavior of the mice of all
these areas in the brain what we found
was that
to a great surprise the neocortex
sounded just fine normal but the Strider
was abnormal so we decided we'd use the
new relatively new method of oxygen
etics bike which an experimenter can
insert molecules into a place in the
brain any place you want and then shine
light on that place in the brain and
either turn on or turn off the cells
what that meant was that we could try to
stimulate that pathway and see what
would whether we could essentially
rescue the animals
Admiral behavior so here I'm holding the
device that is going on the head of the
animal so from there you have all the
micro Drive where you can like
independently move every electrodes and
optical fiber that is delivering the
light so we did that experiment and sure
enough we blocked the compulsion the
minute the light came on and when we
took away the light the animal still
could groove to the water drop which
meant we didn't do anything to their
motor system they were just fine it's
just they didn't act compulsively so we
were pretty excited about that and we
checked out is it could we then you know
make them stop being compulsive when
they are in a train situation it just
being their normal little mouse selves
and sure enough we're good
for this we teamed up with the lab of
coping faint whose Mouse this originally
was amazingly what we found was if we
did stimulate in the cortex with the
very same stimulation that seemed to
cure the compulsion what we got was a
massive in addition of the straddle
cells so you can say okay this sounds
very technical but is there any possible
way this could be abuse so one way we
can help is to say that if people are
going to try to develop next generation
tools to modify
neural activity we can say you know in
Parkinson's disease
some people are treated by deep brain
stimulation and in deep brain
stimulation physician print electrodes
deep into the brain into well-chosen
sites and then they turn the stimulator
on and it basically stays on but maybe
for this kind of disorder obsessive
compulsive disorder or Tourette or any
of any of this kind of flavor of
disorder maybe you don't need to keep it
on all the time maybe if somebody just
says oh I think I think it's coming on
they need to just get a little flick to
the brain even though this does I think
maybe I hope have clinical significance
what we very very much hope is that this
establishes the importance of very basic
science to medicine